yesterday after we finished yesterday's
program as you might imagine logically I
started getting tons of emails and
tweets from people saying David did you
hear huge report about the likely
indictment of Hillary Clinton and so
many people emailed me about this that I
thought something major really must have
broken and it turns out that all that
happened is Fox News's Bret Baier said
that FBI sources that he wouldn't name
told him that the investigation into
Hillary Clinton is much bigger than has
been reported and that an indictment is
likely so let's take a look at what was
actually said first clip is from Bret
Baier on his own program on Fox News
let's start there this is a Fox News
Alert I'm Bret Baier and Washington
breaking news tonight right you separate
sources with intimate knowledge of the
FBI investigations into the Clinton
emails and the Clinton Foundation tell
Fox the following the investigation into
the Clinton Foundation looking into
possible pay-for-play interaction
between Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton and the foundation has been
going on for more than a year right led
by the white-collar crime division
public corruption branch of the Criminal
Investigative Division of the FBI the
Clinton Foundation investigation is a
quote very high priority agents have
interviewed and re interviewed multiple
people about the foundation case and
even before the WikiLeaks dumps these
sources said agents had collected a
great deal of evidence pressed on that
one source said quote a lot of it and
there is an avalanche of new information
coming in every day some of it from
WikiLeaks some from new emails the
agents are actively and aggressively
pursuing this case and they will be
going back and interviewing the same
people again some for the third time
okay so the main point there from from
Brett Bayer and all of what he's saying
is the focus here is the Clinton
Foundation specifically and then Bret
Baier breathlessly going over to Brit
Hume studio to on the seven o'clock
eastern time hour of Fox News I think
say I've been told an indictment against
Hillary Clinton is coming Iran and that
he downplayed in today he
said something that suggests that he's
changed his tune a bit about that
director Comey this does not sound like
something that's going to be completed
anytime soon which suggests that if
Hillary Clinton is elected she will take
office with not one but two serious
investigations of her past conduct
hanging over definitely and I pressed
again and again on this very issue and
these sources said yes the
investigations will continue there's a
lot of evidence and barring some
obstruction in some way they believe
they'll continue to likely an indictment
Wow Wow nice buddy thanks for coming
across the hall at the end of your show
and help us yeah I really appreciate
that no problem this is not proof of
anything right people going apoplectic
over this this is an assertion from Bret
Baier about what he claims he was told
by unnamed FBI sources that doesn't mean
it's false but it says nothing about its
truth there's you know a saying in
Arkansas Pat well there's a saying in
Texas probably one in Arkansas too it
goes fool me once shame on you fool me
twice but well I can't be fooled again
yeah that's really the issue there and
it's possible that these FBI sources are
heavily anti-clinton people there's
every indication from what we've been
seeing from FBI director Comey the press
conference criticized about the press
conference then the letter criticized
about the letter was the letter because
he felt a need to do something because
of the press conference we don't know
there's no doubt that there is an anti
Clinton portion of the FBI and we don't
know what this is and the elections in
three days let's be clear right and as a
journalist it's incumbent on you not to
report misinformation of course this is
Fox News and they're coming from a
biased standpoint but you have to
preface your comments by saying I
believe this is the case or I think this
will happen he didn't do any of them no
doubt and this is why when we report on
the Trump child rape case we're not
saying I believe that this particular
accuser was raped by Donald Trump what
we're saying is how do these allegations
fit into other allegations against Trump
and what are the facts about the
case there is a case there is a hearing
on December 16th the problem is this is
presumably just news and there are some
people whose media literacy is lacking
that's just the reality in this country
and it's not necessarily lacking because
of lack of intelligence it's because
people have lives and they say oh well
you know Fox News six o'clock hour I'm
guessing all of this is fact this is
Bret Baier claiming that someone at the
FBI made a particular assertion
basically five claims were made by Bret
Baier in these two appearances I'll put
them up on the screen for you very
quickly and just run through them number
one that this is an investigation into
the Clinton Foundation and it is very
very extensive number two that there are
laptops which were believed to have been
destroyed of Hillary Clinton aides
Cheryl Mills and Heather Samuelson which
have not been destroyed and are being
looked at number three that there are
emails connected to Anthony Weiner's
laptop and that they are not duplicates
and could potentially have been
classified number four that an
indictment is likely that sort of the
blockbuster and number five the FBI
sources say with 99% accuracy that
Hillary Clinton's server was hacked by
at least five foreign intelligence
agencies bottom line I would be shocked
if there was an indictment against
Hillary Clinton
I've been shocked before and maybe I
will be shocked again but I would be
shocked if there is an indictment
against Hillary Clinton understand what
this is when Bret Baier says it and
understand what it is not